assalamualaikum guys today i'm going to
be playing faris
a game that's set in the ancient muslim
world times
and if you guys want to play as well the
description will be in
uh the box below and don't forget it's
absolutely free
check out inshallah made by muslims
love ilm entertainment presents
forest an adventure game available on
the apple app store in google play store
travel through immersive environments
battle fearsome enemies acquire
legendary items
and unlock awesome achievements
download forest for free and start your
quest
today okay go get the firewood
okay press continue
press down okay
help help
if something bad happens go to the
village elder
one second can i ask a dad's number
so basically the advice was to stay on
the serato mustache
i'll click on the pause button
oh what's this the menu martial
bronze leaf sword equipped
primary confirmed nice
so we know how to equip a weapon now
so we're on the straight path now
oh i'll just make them
oh press the white button on the
let right speak to the gemma
where where are you going
where's the hijabi let's give it that
one
the most thank you is my man glad
the arrogant people here
it's no i'm not allowed to go into the
forest on my own
i've been attacked so this is the battle
mode
i want to run
press fight okay
attack
click on the snake
he's attacked me and it shows that my hp
has gone down
oh click on back
reddit revive player health by 10 hp
let's smash his headphones why is
this is jan hazel
let's go to the bag
click on give for bread like the battle
mode menu
press the triangle on the right then
press the tick button the total number
of bread has gone down
and its health has gone up so this is
how you get your health up outside the
outside of the battle mode what's this
plan
how would you like
okay let me speak to this guy
everyone's giving me an issue above
there's a squad
talk oh this guy's got x what is it
don't harness the world and such a
[Music]
problem
let's plan our two snakes i will be
there okay i'll kill them
i'm not going to kill them
foreign
i need to i need some bread
and i shall have two bread
great job here
this is full of nuts they can reduce
risk of heart disease
yeah i have a lot of cashew nuts
i'll kill them bro [ __ ] them
what's this here what's this here
who's this well it looks chinese
it's not talking
marina
any building that's got no door at the
entrance can be entered
and
disease
they sell swords bro
okay let me go kill some snakes bro
who's this well this person here
okay i'm gonna kill olivia
i'm gonna die maybe guys okay
well i have to make money bro let's
get rich or die trying
because why does he keep attacking me
and i can't attack him back bro
what happens when i die who does
i have to run
soprano i need to eat bread well
is that i got shanked got drunk by three
snakes and i made 48
so apparently
what is pizza hut sponsoring the game
exactly like he told me something big
but of course i know that
this one isn't going to be easy to fight
aki
this guy's on a mad thing bro he gave me
one thing mao
but we'll just be able to beat him
kill him there's po is haram can't eat
this guy he's poking it
level four that's making some mad moves
such a ball look looks like we unlocked
an achievement
let's see if there are any more
where's the night one night what is the
live live event
three doctor panel i wouldn't feel free
though
boy boy boy this is
so much don't pay exclusion please
request to lose your goodies let me slap
this guy's face bro
i had to slap him up
what
is much
just so you guys know rahel is a kurdish
name
so rahel joins our team
well i'm i mean what we need now
so we've got a map let's check it out
we're in the forest and it looks like
we've got to take a left turn
who's this auntie bro
is my boy with me
i'm pressing it there's nothing
happening oh
indeed kill them well
someone
it is better to collect wood in the
forest and send it to them
than beg
i don't cut trees well
mashallah young auntie
as
well
looks like we've got to wait for five
minutes or pay to skip the timer
i'm getting the 99p one remember
brothers and sisters the game
is free so spending a pound here is
nothing
so let's pay the gym fee
is
so it looks like a boss battle is coming
up
what was the more of the story about
is that mystery ball gonna go places
bro
105.
i need to go shrank up some snakes well
actually that's going to take long so
i'll get the five pound in-app purchase
five pound gives you three thousand gems
wow
i'm boring go back to the masjid
let me get some smoked fish 3 000 pounds
i can get anything i like
hmm
i need a shield buff
okay shield what's the centavo
so what's tunic bro
now let's equip these weapons
i'm going to give the false edge sabra
to rahel
and the senti to faris as his secondary
weapon
i'm also going to give the tunic and the
small shield and the small shield to
ferris
now let's see what they do click on
faris
his base attack without any weapon is
12.5 this increases as his level
as he increases as he levels up or with
power ups
and i've given him a secondary weapon
also the tunic has added nine hp his
total hp which is now 57.
now we're ready to fight the boss let's
go do his janaza
oh let me step up this guy
now attacking well
oh and well this guy hits me with that
he hasn't even got a weapon involved
we've got 625 dirhams and we're level 9.
i spy defeat the dressers
what is those on the devil
we received ayatun nur let's check that
out
so it multiplies base attack power by
1.7
and cost 20 ep to use
click on the items menu then click on
the buy button next to the blue elixir
give the elixirs to faris so you can get
up to 20 ep
points
i'm just buying black seeds so i can get
my ep up to capacity
now i'm going to recite i click on faris
then i click on recite i press my ayah
to noor and then choose which enemy to
attack
let's do that with rahel
oh no he doesn't have enough ep points
okay guys i've covered the basics of the
game i'm just going to save it now
the game links are in the description
below so make sure you download it for
free
and make in-app purchases to support the
game